незрозуміло, що алгебра Горвану
Езрі знадобиться як співучасник.
Я не впевнений, що
закон буде змінено, але я думаю, що
будуть зміни в політиці через
увагу, яку петиція привернула
в ЗМІ, я думаю  набагато більше
роботодавців будуть знати про те, чого вони
законно можуть і чого не можуть очікувати, а
саме скаржитися. Я був би
радий планеті Земля. Я все одно думав, що
я сказав вам, що добре, це частково
абсолютно очікування, або
коли ви одягнені на роботі, а я  буде носити
підбори, які працюють на почуття, і я
постійно в дорозі, ми
скорочуємо і не змогли впоратися з цим цього разу,
Холлі, я клянуся, що він насолоджуватиметься цим злочином, а
я дійсно роблю інакше, тому що я думаю, що
ми  що ти хочеш носити і
почуватися комфортно? мій піджак? Що про
те, як ти дивишся на робочу машину? Можеш це записати?
Ти отримуєш ту повітряну кульку? Твоє резюме
ти, так, я створюю, це зазвичай
відволікає так, боже, якщо ти приготував
трохи бренді Bosh mark  привіт що  t так,
це не збірка комп’ютерних сюрпризів